that's right the road to the east runs
through the a in atlanta where the
braves have a four and a half game lead
on a partly cloudy 82 degree humid night
at truest park tukey toussaint will get
this final three-game series underway on
the mound for the braves as tukey
readies with the o2 swaying and a miss a
breaking ball excellent start attack
attack attack four pitches jeff four
strikes one out now what you like is the
fact that he attacked with that fastball
and then went to that curve ball and you
see got tapia way out in front missed
that thing by a foot
three and two for rogers hey came back
to strike him out after a 3-0 count and
you see the movement on it darno sat up
middle plate tukey just threw it and a
lot of sink at 96.
and he lifts this one high in the air
toward left
dansby drifts out he says he has it but
he'll give way to rosario who calls him
off hey great inning for tuki tucson
he's off to a good start in a big game
john gray making his 26th start of the
season we showed you this uh a few
minutes back john has never lost in six
starts to the atlanta braves now what
does he go to
he goes to a slider and uh aussie albies
has to go back to the dugout that's a
heck of a start for big john
i like it curveball slider slider but
the slider to the back foot now albie's
in his career one for 11 against john as
jorge soler hits
and solaire fought that off that's hit
to the right field corner he's got an
11-game streak he's also got a run-out
double here we go good start for atlanta
in the first inning solaire continues to
sizzle so he could be the game's first
run if freddie freeman can knock him in
sharply hit the other way at base here
and here comes celaire around third he
will score without a throw and freddie
freeman continues to sizzle it home the
braves strike first it's one to nothing
atlanta one-nothing for duvall he too
has a 10-game hitting streak for the
braves
and he gets the strikeout of duvall
that's the second of the inning second
out obviously the inning travis darneau
coming up two and two on darneau
and he got either way
swing no swing who was in there so john
ends up striking out the side three hits
uh producer rod freddie freeman with the
ribbing trevor story he's uh really hurt
the braves in his career we'll lead
things off
and trevor hits this straight away and
this one is gone
tie ball game
22nd of the year for story a blast
to dead central he's got four hits on
this road trip three homers and a triple
that ball was crushed last 15 games for
trevor six home runs now
pitch down and in ball four a home run a
fly out and now a walk here in the
rocky's second elias diaz
and this ball is lined to left center
field for diaz cutting the bag and
heading towards third is mcmahon throw
will go to second as it should
first and third one out so as good as
tucson looked in the first the rocky's
getting after him in inning number two
so hampton who had such a wonderful day
on sunday
and that's a base hit to drive in a run
so garrett hampson gives the rockies a
2-1 lead just picking up where he left
off in philly well you got to have all
the confidence in the world if you were
garrett
1-0 count
on the ground big hop for ozzy and that
will retire the side all in all tukey a
nice job to pitch out of further trouble
the rockies strike for two though and
lead by a run you gotta pick somebody
before you do your research
that's strike three that's a pretty good
inning for just getting hit in your
finger huh quick and efficient for big
john in the second rocky's up two to one
and charlie blackman a weak swing and a
miss
that's four strikeouts for tuki tusa
jeff encouraging sign in a stretch of
time in the game where sometimes he has
struggled for the braves skip school for
the baseball game which is totally
acceptable on the ground
dansby takes a long throw to get story
and tooky toussaint after a rough second
breezes through the third loop and a
blast could turn things around here's
darno
fly ball headed for the gap and that
ball is down hamson misplayed that and
darnold's gonna end up at second base
hampson got caught in between and darno
doubles with one out he's the tying run
well there's your break now you got to
cash it in dansby
driven hard toward right center field
blackman on the run not gonna get it
that's off the wall darnold will score
dansby on his way to second that way kid
that's his stroke in the braves and tied
it up it's two to two look at that what
a beautiful pc and that head right on
the ball drives right through it
extension that has to feel good yep top
here right now has struck out and
grounded out on the evening
this uh base hit to start the inning for
tapia lead off single in a 2-2 game in
the fifth with rogers coming up
there he goes and this ball is launched
to deep left field and this one's gonna
sail out of here
two-run home run brendan rodgers
his 12th of the year and the rockies
take a 4-2 lead in the fifth and the
road show continues for rogers 10 of his
12 home runs
away from denver
the slugging roadshow
for the team
we'll bring up garrett hampson
well this ball is well hit to right
solaire
can't make the catch and it kicks back
toward the infield hampton headed
towards third and going out
was albie's i believe to make sure that
wasn't an inside the park home run
that's just a little bit like how you
have to play it at fenway where it might
be an infielder that gets the ball this
ball carry them so hard off this brick
out in right field and then for the
center fielder duval he can't get over
there
so rio ruiz is going to hit for john
gray
he lifts this ball to center field this
should be deep enough the way hampton
runs duvall getting behind it here comes
hampson
and garrett will score easily and it's
five to two nice job by rio ruiz
freddie has an rbi hit tonight
this one cracked towards center hampson
on the run to the warring track he
reaches up can't get it that's off the
wall freddie on his way to second he'll
round the bag he's headed for third and
he will stand with a one-out triple now
let's see if duvall can pick him up
swing in a drive hammer toward the gap
left-center
[Applause]
well adam duvall got a hanger here and
drove it left center
to add to that two out rbi lead for the
mlb but you know what it he just cracked
100 rbi on the year two with 101 now
two on two out what a finish in the
ninth in atlanta
high pop-up this should do it
garrett hampson waiting
hampson's got it and the rockies improve
to 4-1 on this road trip they win game
one in atlanta by the same score that
they won the final game in philadelphia
five to four they utilized some long
ball solid start from john gray and
enough out of the pen
save number eight for carlos estevez